All right, welcome back.
I'm here with Chef Jet Tila
and we're cooking up a classic Pad Thai.
Now, Jet, you just threw in some bean sprouts,
and some scallions, a little peanuts.
Absolutely, we wanna finish with a little bit of crunch.
So here's how we serve this dish in Thailand.
I haven't seen it here,
so I wanted to do it here on your show,
it's called like an egg crepe or like an egg parcel.
So in your pan to the side,
we're gonna just put enough oil to kind of coat the bottom.
It doesn't have to be a lot.
And then, just enough egg to when I kind of swirl,
we coat the bottom.
We're basically just making like an egg pancake,
but there's no flour in here, just egg.
And then, as that's setting up, Drew,
we're gonna take our Pad Thai.
And if yours isn't set up yet,
we've made these ahead of time.
The magic of television.
So you do it that way so we can show our friends at home.
I'm gonna do it in the kitchen style, like in the pan style.
Oh my god, it's like actually setting perfectly.
Isn't that cool?
Yeah, I don't think we need to.
I think it's looking pretty good.
And then, watch.
I'm gonna just wrap the egg and I'm gonna grab a plate.
Do I have a plate?
I'm gonna use this plate right here.
And then, what we do is we're gonna take it,
I'm gonna fold over the sides.
And this is how we do it in Thailand.
We're gonna fold, make a little parcel, all right.
Oh, I'm really watching this.
No, no, wish me luck,
'cause I went a little ambitious.
And let's see if I can do this.
All right, here we go.
Oh!
(audience cheering)
We did it!
Perfect!
We totally did it!
And then, now what we'll do is
it's like a little present that you make
for someone you care about.
So a little bit of Pad Thais there.
Now I wanna do that.
Now you're gonna do it, you're gonna do it totally.
Hey, I have dainty wrists to begin with.
There it is, yes!
Empty.
All right, where's that plate?
Let's get you a plate, let's get you a plate.
All right.
I got your back, okay?
I got you.
All right.
You wanna do this together?
Yes.
Okay.
You invert with me?
Three, two, yeah, yeah, let go!
Yeah!
Oh my god!
You totally did it, look!
Oh!
We did it!
Oh my god, wait!
And it looks awesome!
Mine doesn't suck, Jet.
I told you, you're in good hands.
I got your back, Drew.
Oh my god, I've never done anything like that.
Now look at that, you're all garnished.
Pad Thai, anytime, just like that.
There we go.
(audience cheering)
Stick that over there.
Do we get to the best part now?
Oh, yes.
Try it.
We need to.
Oh my god, I'm so excited.
This is truly my favorite dish.
You nailed the Pad Thai, no joke.
Oh my god, thank you so much.
Oh, it looks piping hot too.
Ooh, it's hot.
(audience cheering)
Mm.
Yes.
Yeah.
(audience cheering)
Thank you for teaching me the way
of one of my very favorite dishes,
and for all the generations of your family
who continue to bring your culinary expertise to the world.
Thank you so much.
It's such an honor.
I thank you for hanging out.
Thanks for letting me teach you Pad Thai.
You gotta get out there and eat more Thai food.
Check it out!
Oh my god, Thai food is my very favorite.
Thank you, Jet Tila!
Jet's book, "101 Thai Dishes That You Need
to Cook Before you Die,"
is available now wherever books are sold.
And that, my friend, is a great way to live,
is to eat these recipes and cook from this book.
(upbeat music)